okay alana and i are at odds because
we're in a group together i say once it
goes free for all we
do not help each other because that's
cheating alana disagrees
no i think you help your friends man
yeah we're playing in a group so should
we help our friends
there's cheating there's a party system
for a reason my dude
yeah that's true though that alana is
correct
it's built this way and that's why
spectate exists you're supposed to look
at your friends and help your friends
i'm feeling good about this sofa you
know i have a coward move but i always
run on the side and you just do not get
hit by this yeah i've started doing that
since i heard you say it
i am brave and stupid and i go through
the middle
i think i got four that was back-to-back
one two three four just so you guys know
i'm gonna get first place in every round
and i'm gonna get the crown every time
okay so you know it's a good time i'm
not very good at this one
yeah this is my worst too jacob i'm
really bad at this i just can't help but
fall into holes you know
nice a lot of nice they're going to grab
a lot get ready to get grabbed
i'm always ready to be grabbed you
should try being able to go into a knife
oh traffic jam oh yeah
i don't have any kind of strat should i
ah watch out long melon coming
avoid large fruits is really that long
melon the whole thing
great oh my god i was on mine the whole
time i'm not
i'm not that's going to get me though
you're doing it thank you i'm really i'm
feeling pretty good goal on it all right
every time i play this one the clock has
run out
yeah really that happened to me the
first time a game too easy is what
you're trying to say
no stay humble
stay humble i'm going to win every one
all right kendrick
what around one person fell is that what
happened two
two two all right big numbers there this
one again all right
don't bump me off this time [ __ ]
okay
they can't hear you bruce you're just
yelling at us only one more needs to die
and i don't want it to be
me it was almost me yeah oh yeah
you're getting there's a pigeon of
course it was a pigeon
oh this one's never played this one oh i
haven't played this one either
it's really fun you just gotta jump i'm
gonna go over here
i'm just gonna run away from it okay
this just seems okay so far
oh
i didn't see it john i'm gonna play
vicariously three years ncaa coming in
okay
it got that controller i got that one
right now some [ __ ] the rocket
league one
still grabbing me some asshole's still
grabbing me some [ __ ] grabbing
okay me started grabbing him first then
bruce yeah because you grabbed me
okay okay chicken or the egg bruce
chicken or the egg
the arbors i know
good times don't work jacob don't tell
me the odds
okay nice star wars what nothing
oh [ __ ] three people are gone you two uh
oh you two are two of the two
uh left
oh i don't feel good about this bruce oh
good job come on you gotta win you gotta
win you gotta win it's you
it's just you no it's there's someone
else
i know but you have to wait for it where
the [ __ ] are they gonna win
oh god
[Laughter]
oh man
yeah classic you bruce how do you think
we got so many twitch subs we know
we know all the way
[Music]
the first time that i did this i got
real boned because i didn't know to jump
for the gap
oh look at that guy who's a box of fries
i haven't had fries in so long jesus you
ever just stop and think about
salted foods how good they are yeah
probably twice a day just stop and think
about some [ __ ] sodium hell yeah dude
oh no no oh [ __ ] i watched you
get that right in front of me that pizza
okay okay can this just oh yeah
please it's a hard knock
it's a hard tilt life for
us oh go blue alana
going blue now we just wait oh pink's on
its way down
now this is just well i've been calling
it purple this whole time you think
that's pink
it's magenta i'm emoting
oh so i took a risk that was
close all right we good we're good
so if i already have a tail i'm just i'm
i would just be running away
somebody immediately that did not last
long oh give me my tail back you stupid
[ __ ]
i lost it i lost tail must get the tail
wait really yeah what the hell green
yes
yeah are we yes oh no
when did that happen oh guys we're not
gonna we're not gonna do it no
no no no no i already might go back
oh we did it i would like to just get
through it
pint this army of pineapples is trying
to push me i know
in other circumstances would be a
wonderful fantasy
please stop this bruce oh the team's all
here oh bad times
one of us must achieve the crown come on
we got this guys
don't hurt each other
i'm sorry i sort of fell in your pocket
bruce that was my bad i did not mean to
oh oh god oh that's so many balls all
the bottles the balls
we did absolutely go the wrong way oh my
god
if that's you john john i don't know if
that is you but it looks like it might
be
jump did you do it
i did it yeah i did it
i just i saw the little the little
pineapple with his little gay skirt and
i was like that's my boy oh
don't touch me knock me off why do
people flip out
okay oh there's some melons in this in
this mix
oh it's so far away oh no no no no oh
oh oh oh i ran out of time to get there
oh my god [ __ ] dinosaurs move faster
where's john i want to watch john and
the fruit oh
oh jacob are you out oh yeah
the fruits last time yeah oh man i hate
this one because
we're you know we're running on a
treadmill
i do passionately hate running on a
treadmill it is one of the
raw things that you can do you got this
god i'm going to do i'm going to do
bruce's goalie
how did that go so wrong so fast it's
all right you guys
still come back you can still come back
goalie baby goalie
oh
[Laughter]
all right let's see how this goes go get
some eggs say john say that uh
whoa what is this i haven't done this
what is this we just go grab it collect
eggs eggs scramble you grab
here's what you do here's what you do
target one
group and don't go for the don't go for
the golds just go
for the normal eggs because i found you
can just
walk in and grab the normal legs and the
team doesn't even care
got it okay
yeah dude yes put that back oh my god
you almost tried to steal your own
egg what is wrong with you it was taking
them out of red and blue
give me that [ __ ] off dude stop grabbing
me
god [ __ ] you go there's a red let me go
all right i want this i would like to
say oh no johnny it's getting too close
john it's good
oh he's getting too close john that's
all right
why am i shooting out of my hand
[Applause]
oh get off my ass what did you change
yourself too johnny oh i fell down
i'm a unicorn that's so cute
i love that for you yes
just yes he says
not necessarily winners but qualifying
top battle
so yeah fairly winners
jacob yeah oh yeah yep
i'm here there's always one
you love this chicken you love it i hate
these [ __ ] ass
purple ass [ __ ] i'll love it until it
[ __ ] me i love it until it [ __ ] me
then it's over jacob fulton ladies and
gentlemen
oh my god
oh my god i got screwed get it
that's their chance
get off
okay doing all right we're doing all
right i don't know if we're gonna
qualify for this one but it's okay
oh oh boy i got a little slippery there
the win is the friends we made along the
way
almost went bad i almost went bad for
old jacob
thanks bruce onwards friends
oh my god oh boy i'm getting crushed oh
my god
it's so funny the way that it literally
turns into a mosh pit and the frame rate
breaks
i love it
good job i broke out i broke out
oh bruce leading the pack yeah he is
i'm a bit scared of these lodgepoles i'm
sorry bruce oh
no oh it's okay it's okay it's okay we
made it we made it watch your face never
hurt anybody
they just look intimidating all right
who's going fast
this is the way all right buddy come on
well you just fell
oh god oh [ __ ] okay push me
this way what what what [ __ ] loop is
that was pointless
wow john you're really leading the pack
there come on yep
come on
did you not make it i didn't even touch
the last platform i jumped over it
that was right i had to sacrifice
sacrifice myself to reveal the next
platform for my team
i genuinely appreciate it it was the
free for all but i'm glad you thought of
it as a team
all right four player lobbies john you
know i'm not gonna help you alana
i do yeah it sucks it's actually like a
huge bubble
oh it's a tail grabber it's a tail
grabber oh but this one's just one
tail grab oh my god run dope with him
now look at that dog go oh he's on his
bike oh come on
i want it so bad he's naruto running
away
get him allah i think he's gonna go
through this way who's my guest
oh he's on the spinning he's on the
spinning
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you got
it and then you lost it that fast i
jumbled
god that's the name of the game
29 seconds dawg mr chance unicorns eat
wolves come on
oh my gosh oh that kind of helped that
helped him that actually helped him yeah
oh he's hesitating that's going to be
his downfall if he's not curious
no oh
oh
yeah we were devastating